Professor Langdon
Hammer: Today,
last Stevens lecture.
Late Stevens,
Stevens after World War Two,
in the late '40s and early
1950s at the end of his life.
That's my subject,
really, the latest writing that
we will have chronologically,
historically,
that we will have discussed so
far.
One of the general themes of
what I had to say has been
modern poetry's role in a
secularizing culture:
how the general decay of
personal religious belief in
practice enters into the way in
which these poets imagine what
poetry is,
what it means for them,
what they can do with it.
"It is a habit with me to be
thinking of some substitute for
religion," Stevens says in a
letter.
"My trouble and the trouble of
a great many people is the loss
of belief in the sort of God in
whom we were all brought up to
believe."
Stevens, however,
responds to this problem
vigorously.
He tends to see it,
as I've been saying,
as an opportunity.
Power and freedom that were
formerly assigned to God are
claimed for man,
for the human,
for the poet in particular,
but the poet viewed in Stevens
not as a kind of exemplary
individual but as a kind of
model of the human and of,
in fact, common properties and
powers within us.
In general, I would say that
the poet stands for a kind of
general human capacity to create
the world in the act of seeing
and describing it,
very much as Marie was arguing
last Wednesday.
Stevens, as I began by saying,
is very much a poet of this
world.
We are an "unhappy people in a
happy world."
The world is,
as "The Auroras of Autumn"
suggests, without malice towards
us.
Original sin,
what Stevens calls "the enigma
of the guilty dream," this is a
kind of exhausted fiction that
Stevens throws off.
He lives in a world that's full
of sensual, seasonal pleasures
and perceptions,
including the primary pleasure
of perception itself;
the seasons providing at once a
kind of "climate," to use his
word, a circumstance,
as well as a symbol for this
way of being and knowing,
knowing our experience.
The seasons are a kind of
answer, you could say,
in Stevens, for traditional
myth, providing a kind of
structure of recurrence and
recovery.
Well, how does such a poet
imagine the end of life,
of his life in particular?
Can a vision of the world
that's so focused on happiness
really include death and loss?
Can it really include in its
account of the world that is so
right, can it really include
grief?
Stevens wants not an
alternative to religion but,
as he says, a substitute for
it;
in particular,
a substitute for the solutions
religion gives to death.
"Poetry is a means of
redemption," Stevens said in
that adage, and he meant it.
But what exactly did he mean by
it?
We'll look at a number of poems
that suggest answers,
beginning with,
on page 260,
a poem called "Large Red Man
Reading," a poem included
in--written after "The Auroras
of Autumn" but included in the
volume called The Auroras of
Autumn:
There were ghosts that
returned to earth to hear his
phrases,
As he sat there reading,
aloud, the great blue tabulae.
They were those from the
wilderness of stars that had
expected more.
[Those that have come to hear
him read.]
There were those that returned
to hear him read from the poem
of life,
Of the pans above the stove,
the pots on the table,
the tulips among them.
[Another sort of domestic
still-life, a little like that
in "Poems of our Climate."]
They were those that would have
wept to step barefoot into
reality.
They would have wept and been
happy, have shivered in the
frost
And cried out to feel it again,
have run fingers over leaves
And against the most coiled
thorn, have seized on what was
ugly
And laughed,
as he sat there reading,
from out of the purple tabulae
[now the tabulae have gotten
redder; they were blue,
now they're purple],
The outlines of being and its
expressings, the syllables of
its law:
Poesis, poesis,
the literal characters,
the vatic lines,
Which in those ears and in
those thin, those spended
hearts,
Took on color,
took on shape and the size of
things as they are
And spoke the feeling for them,
which was what they had
lacked.
This is a version of the
hero-poet in Stevens as a kind
of creative force,
a figure that appears in
Stevens's poems in many guises,
as a "scholar of one candle,"
as the single man,
as a rabbi, as a giant.
In "Notes Toward a Supreme
Fiction," he's called "the
MacCullough."
In what sense is,
however, this creative force
– this giant,
this figure of the poet – a
reader?
What sense does it make to call
the poet a reader?
What the poet does here is read
the world.
Writing is a kind of reading,
for Stevens.
He reads the world as if it
were a poetic text.
His poem is a kind of reading.
It's kind of reading in the
sense of interpretation and in
the sense of reading aloud,
as I've just been doing.
It's a vocalization of "the
outlines of being and its
expressings," to use Stevens's
phrase.
It's a kind of
putting-into-speech of the
world, of experience.
The suggestion is that the
poet's utterance,
which is something that sounds,
it sounds in the ear,
is a kind of decoding of the
primary text of the world,
suggesting that the world is a
kind of poem,
something that can be and must
be read in just the same way
that we read poems on the page.
And in fact,
it's one thing that reading
poems on the page can help us to
do, for Stevens;
that is, in a sense,
learn how to read the world.
Let's look at this figure a
little more closely.
The creator Stevens describes,
here as elsewhere,
is large.
Why?
Well, Stevens himself was.
He was a big guy.
He's large, too,
because he's a parent,
he's a grownup.
He's a kind of consoling and
comprehensive figure in this
poem and in others.
He's also large because he is
an abstraction.
He's in that sense a
generalization.
When Stevens speaks of the
abstract, he doesn't mean the
insubstantial or invisible but
rather the general,
a kind of representative and
summative figure,
made out of many parts.
In this sense,
the large red man is large
because he is a kind of
abstraction.
He is the sum of many parts.
He represents,
as I say, a general human
capacity.
He's red, moreover,
because he's vital,
"primitive" in the sense of
primary or aboriginal.
He is a Native American,
"native" in the sense that he's
a kind of projection of a place,
located in and rooted in the
place.
Adam, after all,
means "red clay," doesn't it?
He's red also because he is
red-blooded.
He's healthy.
And keep in mind that all these
properties are sort of metaphors
or figures for human capacity,
for aspects of voice and of
soul.
And finally,
he's red because he's a reader.
Stevens is punning,
he's suggesting that to be a
reader, to read is to be able to
recognize and speak the language
of the world,
and it is in the process to be
reddened, to be filled with
vitality and life and native
strength and blood,
what Stevens calls in this poem
"feeling."
He "spoke the feeling" for his
auditors, "which is what they
had lacked."
Think of those auditors,
those ghosts who come to hear
the poem, the poem that he's
chanting, as,
well, they're figures of the
dead.
You could think of them as
representing dead parts of
ourselves, ourselves living in
dead ways.
You can see them representing
anyone who comes to poetry in
some state of death or of
deadened feeling,
which is of course the feeling
that the people in The Waste
Land have.
Think of them as anyone who
comes to poetry seeking to know
life and to be creative.
Renewal, regeneration:
this is what the poem gives
them;
it's what Stevens wants.
That's Williams's theme;
it's Stevens's too.
"Poesis": that Greek word means
"making."
Poetry is a means of redemption
because it speaks feeling,
and feeling in Stevens is a
matter of sense,
of sentiment.
Some of Stevens's detractors
– which he has,
it must be admitted – view
him as a kind of sterile
intellectualist.
This is not true.
Stevens is fundamentally a poet
of sentiment and in this way is
in quite conventional ways a
romantic poet.
He has many defenses against
the obvious danger of being a
poet of sentiment,
that is, sentimentality.
How does he avoid being
sentimental?
Well, there's all that nonsense
in Stevens.
There's the impersonality.
There's continually a kind of
acute self-consciousness.
There's abstract discourse.
Stevens is often called,
because of that abstract
discourse, a philosophical poet,
and he is a philosophical poet.
However, we need to understand
what that means in Stevens's
case.
His work raises philosophical
problems and often does so
explicitly;
that is, problems of knowledge
and problems of being,
which are problems of
epistemology,
problems of ontology.
But it's misleading to focus on
these dimensions of his work
without also at the same time
addressing the question of
sentiment.
Again from his Adagia,
Stevens says,
"A poem should be part of one's
sense of life."
sense of life";
"sense" in two senses:
"sense" in the sense of
"understanding" is always
implicated in "sense" as
"feeling," for Stevens.
The priority of sound in
Stevens's poetry--which is the
primary "sense" in poetry for
Stevens – the priority of
sound in Stevens is emblematic
of the priority of feeling in
Stevens and emblematic of the
priority of aesthetics for
Stevens – aesthetics,
the domain of the senses and of
feeling – the priority of
aesthetics over and against
philosophy.
Stevens is a philosophical poet
who includes philosophy as a
kind of partial knowledge within
the larger total knowledge;
that is, a knowledge of feeling
that the aesthetic,
that poetry,
provides and imparts.
Let's look together at three
poems that give a sense of this
total knowledge that I'm talking
about – a total knowledge
representing a kind of unity of
mind and body for Stevens that
incorporates feeling,
incorporates sense.
For example,
"The Poem That Took the Place
of a Mountain" on page 264.
Stevens, like his great
inheritor, John Ashbery,
I think, wrote titles and
collected them and is the author
of not just great poems but
great titles.
And here's one.
Here and in other late Stevens
poems – poems that he wrote
while specifically having in
mind producing or reflecting on
his collected poems – and
incidentally,
this is a kind of dream that
Stevens's whole career is
characterized by;
that is, the sense of creating
a body of work that would be in
some sense total.
His first book is called
Harmonium and it's an
enormous book which he waited a
long time to publish,
and he imagined perhaps
producing a book called The
Whole of Harmonium.
His poem "Notes Toward a
Supreme Fiction" suggests that
ambition to produce,
again, a sort of supreme
fiction, a kind of total poem,
even as that title also admits
the impossibility of doing so.
Here, late in life in 1952,
he is contemplating his career
as a whole and the body of work
he has produced,
and this is a poem reflecting
on that.
There it was,
word for word,
The poem that took the place of
a mountain.
He breathed its oxygen,
Even when the book lay turned
in the dust of his table.
It reminded him how he had
needed
A place to go in his own
direction [when he began],
How [in the process of creating
that body of work]
he had recomposed
the pines,
Shifted the rocks and picked
his way among clouds,
For the outlook that would be
right,
Where he would be complete in
an unexplained completion:
The exact rock where his
inexactnesses
Would discover,
at last, the view toward which
they had edged,
Where he could lie and,
gazing down at the sea,
Recognize his unique and
solitary home.
Here, producing a poem,
producing a body of poetry,
living in poetry in the way
Stevens has done,
is like climbing a mountain;
or rather, it's like both
creating and climbing the
mountain – both those things,
step by step or "word for
word."
That's that interesting phrase
that the poem begins with.
Usually, we use that phrase to
describe what?
A kind of transcription;
it was a "word for word"
transcript or a translation:
translation.
It suggests that the poem that
Stevens is talking about is,
in some sense,
a transcription or translation,
word for word,
which suggests in turn that the
world was, even before it was
put into language,
already a kind of language,
a set of words,
a text.
This develops the idea that the
poet in Stevens is a reader.
Writing here is an act of
rendering the words of the
world, making them over into the
poet's words,
and making them in this process
available in and through his
words.
What is the nature of this
translation or substitution?
The phrase "took the place of"
connotes both displacement and
compensation.
The poem took the place of a
mountain;
it displaces it.
It also compensates for the
loss of it.
The world is somehow lost
always in experience but then
also found again in writing,
in the act of creation that
Stevens refers to as expressing
his need of a place to go in his
own direction.
"It reminded him how he had
needed / a place to go in his
own direction."
That could almost be Frost.
That's the kind of phrase Frost
might have used.
It suggests both a kind of
public ambition perhaps,
also personal and private
escape;
some kind of,
in any case,
claim for independence and
originality, eccentricity even.
It says that in remaking the
world in language,
in the act of going in his own
direction,
the poet has created a certain
point of view,
a perspective on experience.
It's what Stevens will call
"his unique and solitary home":
the world according to himself,
which is as it must be for all
of us.
Stevens says,
"he would be complete in an
unexplained completion,"
"completion" meaning "the end of
the climb,"
that his creation must go
beyond explanation in the same
way that poetry,
the aesthetic,
must pass beyond philosophy.
Stevens says in another poem
that poetry "must resist the
intelligence,
/ Almost successfully."
He's interested in an
unexplained completion.
He values poetry's
"inexactnesses."
It's an interesting word.
His inexactnesses carry him
along as he climbs edgewise –
he "edges" – with the
implication that,
I suppose, on a mountain top,
which is a precarious place
where the ground is steep and
unstable,
you can only proceed carefully.
You can only proceed by edging
along.
Poetry's path,
in Stevens, is oblique.
"Tell all the truth but tell it
slant," Emily Dickinson said.
Stevens's telling is oblique,
slanted.
He moves edgewise in his poems.
He goes up the side of his high
subjects.
Yet in this way,
he gives poetry in the end a
view of the whole.
And for all of its imaginings
and for all of its celebration
of imagining,
for all of its celebration of
poetry's power to displace the
world and take the place of a
mountain,
the poem rests on a rock that
is real: the rock of the real,
which is a metaphor that recurs
over and over again in Stevens's
late poetry.
You could keep in mind another
one of Stevens's adages,
one of his late adages:
"The real," he says,
"is only the base,
but it is the base."
This could be a kind of
epigraph for this poem and many
other Stevens poems,
and it's an important idea to
keep in mind as you try to think
about the relationship between
imagination and reality in
Stevens.
Along with the idea,
in fact, that Stevens is a
philosophical poet and a kind of
intellectualist,
there is the idea that he is an
idealist who,
because he believes in the
power of the mind to bring
reality into being,
denies the reality of the
physical world.
This is another mistake,
as that adage about the real
and the base suggests.
Stevens's last book of poems
was called The Rock.
There are many images of
material reality in late
Stevens, and they're important.
Look at "The Plain Sense of
Things" on page 266,
another late poem.
Think of how many of these
poems focus on moments of
seasonal transition.
Here's another.
After the leaves have
fallen, we return
To a plain sense of things.
[And there's that word "sense"
again, in all of
its multiple senses.]
It is as if
We had come to an end of the
imagination,
Inanimate in an inert
savoir.
And he continues:
Yet the absence of the
imagination had
Itself to be imagined.
The great pond,
The plain sense of it,
without reflections,
leaves,
Mud, water like dirty glass,
expressing silence
Of a sort, silence of a rat
come out to see,
The great pond and its waste of
the lilies, all this
Had to be imagined as an
inevitable knowledge,
Required, as a necessity
requires.
Here, Stevens is imagining the
end of the fall,
imagining what is beyond
imagination;
imagining, too,
where imagination ends,
where it tends,
and its goal.
Compare this to a late poem
like "Circus Animals' Desertion"
in Yeats where the poet descends
from the ladders of imagination
" the foul rag and bone shop of
the heart."
Stevens is treating this theme
himself in somewhat different
terms.
You could also compare this
poem to "Poems From Our Climate"
and the will to come to primary
terms in that poem,
or "The Man on the Dump";
just as in "Poems of Our
Climate," as Stevens does arrive
at something like primary terms,
what he calls here "the plain
sense of things," what might be
a limit or base for imagination,
the real.
His poem moves to recover and
reassert the power of
imagination.
Even the end of imagination,
he says, "had to be imagined as
an inevitable knowledge" – an
inevitable knowledge:
a phrase that equivocates as to
whether this knowledge had to be
imagined of necessity or whether
its necessity had itself to be
imagined,
which is an idea that reasserts
the dominance of the mind even
in its defeat,
you could say.
And in this sense,
the poem is a small example of
that long tradition of the
Kantian sublime,
where the mind is somehow
checked and awed by natural
force or natural powers –
something greater than itself
– and then recovers its
strength as it recognizes that
this defeat is itself a kind of
mental representation or
construction.
External reality,
its endurance and its
materiality, is,
in fact, a consoling fact for
Stevens,
which he affirms in another
poem, a poem not in your
anthology but one of my
favorites,
placed last in his Collected
Poems and in your RIS
packet.
It's called "Not Ideas About
the Thing but the Thing Itself."
Again, a kind of--The title
suggests a kind of encounter
with reality in its primary
forms.
Placed here,
at the very end of his
Collected Poems,
it was a kind of last poem,
though it was not by any means
the last poem he would write.
At the earliest ending of
winter [and now it's not the end
of fall but rather
the end of winter that Stevens
is writing about],
In March, a scrawny cry from
outside [and that's a
wonderfully resonate
phrase--outside the room,
outside the mind]
Seemed like a sound
[nonetheless]
in his mind.
He knew that he heard it,
A bird's cry,
at daylight or before,
In the early March wind.
The sun was rising at six,
No longer a battered panache
above snow…
It would have been outside.
It was not from the vast
ventriloquism
Of sleep's faded
papier-mâché… [It wasn't
something I dreamed or made up,
it can't have been.]
The sun was coming from outside.
That scrawny cry [and he comes
back to that word]--it was
A chorister whose c preceded
the choir.
It was part of the colossal sun,
Surrounded by its choral rings,
Still far away.
It was like
A new knowledge of
reality.
The poem begins with a
confusion of inner and outer.
The cry that the poet hears,
he wants to say is outside him;
it's important for him to say
it's outside him.
Why?
If it's not outside him then
the sign of life that it gives
and the promise of life's
continuance would be his own
projection and would be
something liable to die with
him.
He wants proof that the world
will go on without him,
that spring will come again.
The cry is a kind of elemental
noise, the noise of the elements
themselves and the sound of the
seasons changing.
It is a complaint,
a lament, alarm,
exclamation,
and shout for joy.
It's the sound of daytime
returning, and with it spring at
the earliest moment,
a kind of emergence from winter
and death.
Stevens is a poet of change but
of change within regenerative
cycles, of which night and day
and the seasons themselves are
primary instances and symbols.
Notice also that the world
makes itself known here in and
as sound.
Life is something you hear.
This also is like Frost.
The world is again a kind of
language.
It's speaking to us.
Stevens, in describing it
through metaphors and similes
and finding words for it,
is performing an act of reading
again, of transcription,
and of translation.
In particular,
he is providing figurative
language for understanding it.
He calls the cry "scrawny."
It's a great word;
he uses it twice.
What kinds of things are
scrawny?
Babies are scrawny, right?
Old men are scrawny, both.
Here both ideas are held
together at this moment of
seasonal transition when the
year is old and the year is new
at the same time.
That single bird that gives
that cry is the poet's double,
a kind of echo.
Maybe each are echoes of the
other.
The bird suggests an image of
how the poet himself is
integrated into the creative
event that is the simple,
ordinary return of the world
with dawn.
The poet, like the bird,
is merely a chorister,
a voice among other voices in a
kind of harmonium that is total
and whole.
In this case,
his "c precedes the choir";
that is, all the other voices
that are going to follow this
first one in the morning.
That "c" tunes them.
Here, alliteration is important.
It links the cry and the choir
and the chorister and the choral
rings and the colossal sun that
generates all of them in a
series of rings,
choral rings and vocal rings.
And it's a wonderful image of
synesthesia.
This is light coming as sound
and sound as light at once,
a kind of total sensory
experience.
Stevens is imaging morning,
imagining it as a kind of
synesthetic event and as the
arrival of a series of linked
creativities,
all derived from the colossal
sun of which the poem's bold and
somewhat simple,
playful, and almost childlike
alliteration and punning are
instances, are simply forms of
this choral music.
The poem's linguistic play,
in other words,
displays the poet's power to
link the things of the world
through sound,
to produce connections between
them through words,
and is itself a kind of model
and a case of those choral rings
through which the world is
coming into being.
Steven's poem,
in other words,
is a small version of the
creative event it's describing.
It is like "a new knowledge of
reality," he says:
"new" because refreshed,
newly experienced and newly
activated.
It's also a knowledge of
reality existing exactly in its
newness.
The real is what is new,
what is emerging,
and what is fresh,
carrying change to us.
Pay attention to the sun in all
of Stevens's poems but
especially in these late poems
where the sun is a kind of
mythic presence.
The poet waits for the sun with
the heroine Penelope in the
world as meditation.
Penelope there is the sun's
bride, Ulysses' wife.
Look at that poem as a kind of
late sublime version of "Sunday
Morning."
Another version of the sun,
of this heroic creative figure
is the giant in the poem called
"A Primitive Like an Orb."
This is a somewhat longer poem
and I'd like to look at some of
its parts with you.
The question in this poem,
which is in your RIS packet,
is really the same question as
is posed by "Not Ideas About the
Thing…" and that is:
what is the relationship
between Stevens's poem and the
poems of the world?
What is the link between his
creativity, or our creativity,
in this larger system of
creation that Stevens's poetry
evokes?
Or in the language of this
poem, what is the relationship
between Stevens's poems and the
"essential poem at the center of
things"?
Let me read the second section
first.
"The essential poem at the
center of things" is the first
line.
It's kind of the theme that he
will now explore.
And he says about it:
We do not prove the
existence of the poem.
[We can't prove this kind of
bigger thing.
Rather…]
It is something seen and known
in lesser poems [in parts].
It is the huge,
high harmony that sounds
A little and a little, suddenly
By means of a separate sense.
It is and it
Is not and, therefore, is.
In the instant of speech,
The breadth of an accelerando
moves,
Captives the being,
widens--and was there.
You can't grasp it;
it passes.
That "separate sense" is the
sense that Steven's poems want
to get at in their
inexactnesses,
sometimes in their nonsense.
They're gesturing towards it.
It's the existence of that
separate sense which is a sense
of the whole,
of a kind of totality,
and is affirmed precisely
through its invisibility,
its non-existence.
"It is and it / Is not and,
therefore, is."
It exists in its
inaccessibility,
in the fact that it is always
gone.
It was always just there.
We feel it only ever in its
parts, which are synecdoches
linked to the whole,
like the scrawny cry and the
choral rings of the colossal
sun.
They are parts that point to a
whole.
Stevens carries this idea
forward then in section four.
Here he is rewriting Theseus'
lines from A Midsummer
Night's Dream:
"The poet, the lunatic,
and the lover are of
imagination all compact."
Here he says:
One poem proves another
and the whole,
For the clairvoyant men that
need no proof:
[who are they?]
The lover, the believer and the
poet.
Their words are chosen out of
their desire,
[that's important in Stevens--
and remember desire is "hot" in
us.
What is desire?
It is]
The joy of language,
[is it something apart from us?
No it's in us] when it
is themselves.
With these [with these words,
the words "chosen out of
desire," by the lover,
the believer,
the poet]
they celebrate the central
poem,
The fulfillment of
fulfillments,
in opulent,
Last terms, the largest [and
now he's going to start to get a
little carried
away], bulging still with more,
[coma, moving on to the next
stanza]
Until the used-to earth and
sky, and the tree
And cloud, the used-to tree and
used-to cloud [what was there a
moment before],
Lose the old uses that they
made of them,
And they: these men,
and earth and sky,
inform
Each other by sharp
informations,
sharp,
Free knowledges,
secreted until then,
Breaches of that which held
them fast.
It is
As if the central poem became
the world,
And the world the central poem,
each one the mate
Of the other [and you can think
about how often one finds images
of
wedding or of mating in
Stevens, such as in "The World
as Meditation"],
as if summer was a spouse,
Espoused each morning,
each long afternoon,
And the mate of summer:
her mirror and her look…
The essential poem begets the
others.
[It creates the others.]
The light
Of it is not a light apart,
up-hill.
Rather, it exists down below in
all of its component parts.
Let me read now sections seven
and following.
It is one of the great
sentences in modern poetry.
The poem begins with a
declaration: "The central poem
is the poem of the whole."
This might seem to say it all,
but rather, this declaration,
this principle is a generative
one that will now go on
generating verse,
much as this principle in the
world goes on generating the
world that we experience.
The central poem is the
poem of the whole,
The poem of the composition of
the whole,
The composition of blue sea and
of green,
Of blue light and of green,
as lesser poems,
And the miraculous multiplex of
lesser poems…
And again, by "poems" he means
individual poems;
he also means individual
perceptions, individual creative
acts.
All are forms of making in the
world.
"The miraculous multiplex of
lesser poems" are brought then:
Not merely into a whole,
but a poem of
The whole, the essential that
is compact of its parts,
The roundness that pulls tight
the final ring
And that which in an altitude
would soar,
A vis [a power],
a principle or,
it may be,
The meditation of a principle,
Or else [and here's Stevens's
incredible rhetorical and
imaginative ability
to keep going and say "or" and
go on imagining things]
an inherent order
active to be
Itself, a nature to its natives
all
Beneficence,
a repose, utmost repose,
The muscles of a magnet aptly
felt [this is what this total
being, this total
poem that he is imagining is
like.
And as he imagines it,
as a totality,
he
starts to imagine it as a
person],
A giant, on the horizon,
glistening,
And in bright excellence
adorned, crested
With every prodigal,
familiar fire,
And unfamiliar escapades:
whirroos
And scintillant sizzlings such
as children like,
Vested in the serious folds of
majesty,
Moving around and behind,
a following,
A source of trumpeting seraphs
in the eye,
A source of pleasant outbursts
on the ear.
It's a wonderful vision.
It calls to mind the great
appearance, the great spectacle
of the appearance of the world
seen here suddenly as a kind of
majestic giant figure
approaching us with the folds of
royal garments.
That's what appearance is like
for Stevens.
And I think of the weather,
the hills of Connecticut – a
Sleeping Giant itself – as
Stevens imagines a kind of
experience of the landscape and
of the world as humanized,
a kind of humanized totality.
That is, it's like a kind of
generalized and abstract image
of the human;
an image of the human that is
realized for Stevens in and
through play.
These garments,
they're something that pleasure
children and that pleasure us as
children are pleasured.
The giant is a kind of image of
the essential poem,
as he calls it,
and he will go on to describe
it a little bit further.
He now says:
Here, then [in section
eleven], is an abstraction given
head [what he's talking about is
this general poem that's "given
head" in the sense of
"allowed to go and expand and
have its way," but also
anthropomorphized,
becoming],
A giant on the horizon,
given arms [in fact],
A massive body and long legs,
stretched out,
A definition with an
illustration [that is,
the world is at once "a
definition
with an illustration"], not
Too exactly labelled,
a large among the smalls
Of it, a close,
parental magnitude,
At the centre on the horizon,
concentrum, grave
And prodigious person,
patron of origins.
Here, man is not created in
God's image, but rather this
image is of God created in
man's,
brought into being through play
and through all the senses of
sense, representing a
"definition with an
illustration" – a picture in
word: again,
abstract and concrete,
an aesthetic whole that
includes a kind of philosophical
knowledge in it.
This is what all art for
Stevens aims at.
He says simply:
That's it.
The lover writes,
the believer hears,
The poet mumbles and the
painter sees,
Each one, his fated
eccentricity,
As a part, [everything we do is
a part, only a part]
but part, but tenacious
particle,
Of the skeleton of the ether,
[this big giant thing]...
…perceptions, clods
Of color, the giant of
nothingness, each one [each one
of us, each one thing that we
do]
And the giant ever changing,
living in change.
"That's it," meaning,
that's the end of imagination.
It's the sense of its ending,
its terminus,
and its goal.
But it turns out to be no
ending at all but rather an
experience of a whole that is
ongoing,
that is an experience of change
that includes death,
and includes our own deaths,
in a kind of totality that is
ever changing and living
precisely in change.
Well, we'll go on to a very
different poet on Wednesday –
W.H.